pour leur a demandé de rentrer la
religion dans l'espace privé ils l'ont
fait vous si vous voulez ce que nous
demandons ça n'est pas aux gens de
renoncer c'est de comprendre que ça
heures plusieurs choses chez nous 1
effectivement la discrétion dans
l'espace public on ne jette pas sa
religion à la passe d audit chez nous
vous parlez de ti par 100 francs qu'elle
nous en france connaissent pas et nous
en france en seine se reconnaissent dans
notre pays dans notre pays qui est un
pays singulier parce qu'il ya deux
modèles cvo bohlega le multiculturalisme
c'est mc donald's venez comme vous êtes
ça marche pas très bien on prête même
eia l'assimilation républicaine
c'est à dire à rome tu fais comme les
romains les moeurs françaises la mini
jupe mais mini jupe n'a pas le même
statut que votre burkini parce que votre
burkini n'est pas français vous vous
êtes française mais votre burkini ne
l'est pas est ce qu on demande
simplement à l'islam et à toutes les
eaux toutes les autres cultures comme
elles l'ont fait avant si vous voulez
c'est de dire nous nous adaptons nous
nous adaptons il y à signaler 70 % de
vos concitoyens qui sont heurtés par
cette pratique c'est parce que ça leur
notre conception de la liberté des
femmes elle sait nous le corps des
femmes n'a pas ce catch est d'accord et
que ça heurte aussi notre conception
d'une certaine unité nos différentes
bien sûr existe mais dans le fond les
héros ou les exhibe le moins possible
sur la place publique voilà et ça n'est
pas du tout une question de racisme et
encore moins une question d'animosité
contre vous mais oui l'habillant société
suppose de renoncer à certaines libertés
et la france c'est pas mac do d'accord
je pense qu'il n'y a pas d'animosité
envers moi personnellement je vous crois
mais il y avait quelque chose contre
l'islam je pense moi ce que je vais vous
dire déjà c'est que le burqini n'est pas
une histoire on va dire ne concerne pas
que les musulmanes ce n'est pas de base
il a été créé par une styliste
australienne donc rien à voir avec avec
une femme de arabie saoudite ou de lire
en tout cas je tourne surtout temps ces
exemples exemple là une femme qui vivait
dans un pays libre qui a vu qu'il y
avait que des femmes avaient du mal on
va dire à adapter leur style de vie avec
leurs croyances qui a eu l'idée qui
s'est inspiré en fait d'une combinaison
qui existait déjà depuis des années qui
n'a jamais fait polémique c'est à dire
la combinaison de surf où les
combinaisons de plongée qui a été adapté
en fait pour les femmes pour qu'elles
puissent justement pratiquer leur sport
ou leur passion enfin pouvoir participer
à des loisirs avec leurs enfants
sans justement on va dire pas dénigrer
mais mettre de côté leurs valeurs et
leurs croyances et je voulais vous dire
que justement super clean et le conte ce
ne n'est pas porté que par des
musulmanes aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
femmes qui ne sont même pas religieuse
croyantes ou enfin qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la religion et qui le porte juste
savoir quand même soit c'est rare mais
ça existe il ya aussi des femmes qui
sont chrétiennes qui sont voilées de la
même manière que moi je vais vous me
prenez un peu pour à la panne trois
semaines là comme dit pascal praud s'est
excusé moi c'est que vous essayez de le
dire que c'est un vêtement parmi
d'autres choix non aux ordres et athmane
fumée le fait que c'est un choix qui a
quelque chose à voir avec votre identité
ou culturelles et religieuses
connotation à écouter en fait je dirais
le dépend pourtant quoi il est interdit
au maroc d'après vous je ne suis pas
enseignée sur ses biens il est interdit
au maroc pourquoi parce que les
marocains savent que c'est une arme si
vous voulez de conquête des islamistes
alors j'essaie une conquête vous touchez
le tissu si vous souhaitez je vous
invite à venir le voir non mais c'est
pas bête n'y a rien
c'est pas un vêtement c'est un symbole